l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Monsieur André Richard un
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue merci monsieur le
Président je suis le ministre le crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi a été présenté par le
gouvernement comme l'une des mesures
économiques majeures
il a pour objet de contribuer à
l'amélioration de la compétitivité des
entreprises lesquelles en ont bien
besoin dont le contexte de compétitivité
économique féroce qu'elle connaisse
actuellement
toute entreprise peut bénéficier de ce
dispositif à la condition toutefois quel
verse des salaires puisque c'est sur la
masse salariale vous le savez bien que
porte le cice et c'est là bien sûr que
le bât blesse c'est la notamment que se
trouve le problème les entreprises
individuelles qui n'ont pas de salariés
se retrouvent injustement exclus de ce
dispositif le secteur de l'artisanat en
particulier s'en trouve fortement
pénalisés nombreux sont les artisans
indépendants travaillant seuls et dans
ces conditions il ne bénéficie pas du
cice
ceci ont préféré l'indépendance
l'engagement le risque est contribue au
moins autant que les autres acteurs
économiques à la production de richesses
leur mise à l'écart est à mon sens une
erreur qu'il convient de corriger très
vite
selon les chiffres de l'INSEE il existe
54000 entreprises individuelles
artisanales et plus de la moitié n'ont
aucun salarié or toutes ces entreprises
qui n'ont pas accès aux dispositif
rencontre elle aussi bien sûr d'énormes
difficultés de fonctionnement des
difficultés de trésorerie
particulièrement elles sont souvent
d'ailleurs pour un certain nombre
d'entre elles de jeunes entreprises qui
ont besoin d'oxygène pour prendre leur
marque sur le marché avant de nous
l'espérons tous se développer et créer
de l'emploi
monsieur le ministre je vous suppose en
accord avec ce postulat nous devons
soutenir le secteur de l'artisanat qui
est un volet fondamental du tissu
économique de notre pays d'abord ma
question est la suivante allez-vous
étendre à ces entreprises qui sont des
acteurs économiques importants au même
titre que d'autres le bénéfice du cice
ou de tout autre dispositif que
j'appelle de mes vœux pour réduire leur
charge ou autrement dit encore plus
simplement pouvez-vous me dire quelle
mesure vous comptez prendre pour
compenser cette inégalité de traitement
actuel entre deux types d'entreprises
celles qui ont des salariés et celles
qui n'en ont pas je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Richard monsieur le
ministre
monsieur sénateur vous m'interrogez sur
le crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
et l'emploi permettez-moi tout d'abord
d'excuser le ministre de l'économie et
des finances qui est aujourd'hui retenue
par rendez-vous avec des entreprises le
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
l'emploi mesure phare du Pacte pour la
croissance la compétitivité l'emploi
bénéficie à l'ensemble des entreprises
employant des salariés imposés à la peau
sur les sociétés ou à l'impôt sur le
revenu d'après leur bénéfice net quel
que soit le mode d'exploitation
entreprise individuelle c'est-à-dire
indépendant société de personnes société
de capitaux et quel que soit le secteur
d'activité agricole artisanale
commerciale
industriels et de services pour 2013 le
crédit d'impôt équivaut à 4% de la masse
salariale hors salaire supérieur à 2,5
fois le SMIC à partir de 2014 ce taux se
rapportait à 6%
par construction s'agissant d'un crédit
d'impôts assis sur la masse salariale
des entreprises éligibles les
entreprises sans salariés ne peuvent pas
en bénéficier il ne s'agit pas du
injustice et d'une caractéristique
essentielle du crédit d'impôt contenu
des objectifs que le législateur lui a
signé c'est à dire la réduction du coût
du travail le cice vise en effet à
stimuler la compétitivité coût des
entreprises françaises en allégeant leur
charge salariale or le revenu du
travailleur indépendant des pages
juridiquement à salaire et n'est pas en
terme comptable un coup pour
l'entreprise il constitue au contraire
le bénéfice de l'entreprise
économiquement le cice et l'équivalent
d'une baisse de cotisation patronale sur
les salaires il est d'ailleurs
comptabilisé comme tel au crédit d'un
sous compte dédié du compte 64 charge de
personnel suivant la recommandation de
l'Autorité des normes comptables dans
une note du 28
février 2013 d'autre part le cice vise à
encourager l'embauche
article 244 quatrc mentionne en son
alinéa que le cice doit permettre de
financer des efforts en matière de
recrutement
compte tenu cet objectif il serait
paradoxal d'accord dès le crédit d'impôt
au chef d'entreprise sans salariés enfin
à titre subsidiaire le calcul du cice
suppose de connaître le temps de travail
des salariés afin de déterminer si à
leur rémunération entre ou non dans
l'assiette du crédit d'impôt ce dernier
s'applique en effet au seul rémunération
n'excédant pas deux fois et demi de
salaire minimum de croissance calculé
pour un an sur la base de la durée
légale du travail augmenter le cas
échéant du nombre d'heures
complémentaires ou supplémentaires sans
prise en compte des majorations
auxquelles elle donne lieu pour des
travailleurs indépendants qui ne
décompte par leur durée de travail
l'application d'une telle méthode de
calcul présenterez incontestablement de
sérieuse difficulté pour toutes ces
raisons monsieur le sénatoy n'est pas
envisagé de revenir sur la définition de
l'assiette de crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité
merci monsieur le ministre
sur achat
muscle j'ai bien compris les raisons qui
vous poussent à ne pas revenir sur les
modalités de ce cice
je voudrais néanmoins insister sur le
fait que ces petites entreprises par
définition l'entreprise individuelle
sans salariés est une petite entreprise
sont confrontées à l'heure actuelle à
d'énormes difficultés qui exigeraient
également une réduction de leur charge
précisément dès lors que le revenu pour
un travailleur indépendant n'est pas un
salaire il convient de faire en sorte
que ce même revenu puisse bénéficier
d'une exonération une réduction de de
ces charges vous avez bien compris qu'à
l'heure actuelle
malgré la réforme entreprise à l'heure
actuelle par le gouvernement en ce qui
concerne
le régime des auto-entrepreneurs ces
entreprises individuelles souffrent
particulièrement d'une concurrence
occasionnée par ces derniers il est
évident que cette catégorie
d'entreprises attendent des mesures
également tout à fait importante et
j'insiste sur ce cette conclusion de mon
discours tout à l'heure dans la mesure
où il s'agit très souvent de petites
entreprises qui viennent de se créer
leur donner un minimum d'oxygène pour
qu'elle puisse trouver les marques leur
marque sur un marché difficile leur
permettrait à non pas douter de se
développer de ce conforter et derrière
cela de créer de l'emploi je vous
remercie de bien vouloir si ce n'est pas
possible à travers le séisme ce que je
peux bien comprendre je vous remercie de
bien vouloir examiner la possibilité de
le renvoyer d'une façon d'une autre un
ascenseur leur renvoyer l'ascenseur
compte tenu des charges qu'elle paye à
l'heure actuelle dans un contexte je
l'ai dit particulièrement difficile